[Music]
and of course what would halloween be
without
a spooky dish or two nanny bobby is here
to show us how to make
mummy dogs happy halloween how you doing
i'm great kendall it's so great to be
back with you and the team over there
live at least here we are in nanny
bubby's kitchen
i love great to have you here as well
you are making some mummy dogs what kind
of hot dogs should we use for this
there we go so my favorite to use is the
hebrew national quarter pounders it's
because they're
large and they're really easy to wrap
and the second thing that we're using
that i think you're going to love is
these crescent rolls
they're very they're pillsbury they're
pre-made and what we're going to do
is we on we open up that of course that
needs not to be said
we unroll it into the triangles are you
with me here kendall can you see it yeah
are those like bandages
yeah and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna cut them
starting with the lengthwise like that
right like that so i
pre-cut these so that we can go very
very quickly
and the first thing you're going to do
is just wrap it around the head because
you need a place to put the eyes
so we're going to go around and by the
way this is a very messy job it doesn't
have to be perfect as you can see
that broke off over there we're going to
take the small piece and put it on as
kind of like the hat
of the mummy because the eyes are going
to go right there we'll put the eyes and
you can see this
that i've done pre where it's wrapped
there we go we're going to grab another
strip
and believe me so who does the cooking
at your house kendall you or your wife
or both yeah i do most of the cooking
actually i do a lot of them
okay so this is a messy job and it's
great for big hands because you don't
have to worry about how you do it
how you pull it around just peeling up
and across and it's great for kids too
because it can be messy and you don't
have to worry about it i'm going to put
one more on
there we go we're going to take it like
that we're going to put these
into the oven i've got four here we're
going to take them and put them into the
oven for about 18 minutes
just like that don't they look great and
what's the temperature
uh 375 degrees okay and you can follow
me
into our chapman oven right our tv
sponsor
and because of the magic of television i
love the magic of tv
yes we already have four of them made
for you
and what i'm going to show you right now
is how to add the eyes so the fun part
of these here let me grab this one
is that you're going to stick eyes right
there and these are eyes that come right
out of the cake
section of any normal grocery store
um they're used for cookies and things
who knew and
we're going to use ketchup or mustard i
prefer mustard
right here i'm with you yep well i
prefer the mustard for this
because it's thicker and the eyes let's
see are you getting that there you seen
the close-up of that
there we go oh i can't get these eyes
out
hold on hot dogs anyway
i do too especially hebrew national for
some reason i like it better
and there we go there's the eyes can you
see that wow
that's great isn't that fantastic so you
know at the end of every segment i
always say
this pairs nicely with this bottle of
wine
or with this side dish or whatever you
might think of
but this pairs nicely i'll put one more
eye on here
what do you think this pairs nicely with
kendall uh root beer
well you're close what else um well i
would always say dr pepper i mean if
you're talking to me that's that's
everything yeah
right i know you're a dr pepper guy
there's another one right
love it okay one more but i'm assuming
i'm assuming because the kids are
helping you make this we're not pairing
this with wine this time
we're not pairing it with wine but what
do you think most kids want
uh lemonade um on a cold halloween night
now
you're talking you're talking summertime
there we go how cute is that
hot chocolate there you go so you got it
so we'll turn this around
look how cute those are with the help of
my producer natalia she
i cheated she told me in my ear did she
all right this pairs nicely with hot
chocolate
right into the cup
and guess what else a kit kat
of course because i'm a kitty cat
yep and a reese's peanut butter cup and
you have dinner
for a cold halloween night for your kids
and for yourself i love it how do you
like that
that is a fun fun activity on top of
everything else
and you end up with a great meal for the
kids
you do it's so good to be with you and
everyone else
and i hope to see you again soon soon i
hope to be back in the studio yes
we miss you here all right i miss you
too
always always good to talk to you check
out nanny bubby's kitchen and garden on
social media
and online at nannybubby.com we also
want to thank chapman automotive
for sponsoring the segment